A-list actor camping gear spokesman
makeup artist Jeremy Renner has worn
many hats throughout his life these are
some of the weirder Parts you may have
forgotten about
a lot of celebrities launched apps in
the mid-2010s and Jeremy Renner
certainly wasn't the only one who lacked
Kardashian level Fame at the time so
while the Genesis of the Jeremy Renner
app certainly makes the actor appear a
little eccentric it might not have
seemed like a totally insane idea in
2017. today the Jeremy Renner app
absolutely seems like a totally insane
idea but that's only because of our
power of hindsight sadly the Jeremy
Renner app devolved into a cluster muck
of Mythic proportions folks didn't
always comprehend what it was supposed
to do or why it should cost money its
service was prone to glitches and
confusing info trolls impersonating
Runner and potentially upsetting figures
like O.J Simpson and Casey Anthony
inundated the service in 2019 Renner
himself pulled the plug while we
obviously don't have any knowledge of
the man's personal finances it's
possible Jeremy Renner doesn't need to
continue acting even if Marvel decided
to kill off Clint Barton it's not like
he'd be wanting for roles or presumably
money ever since his acting career began
generating cash in the early 2000s
renners cultivated a side business
business in buying renovating and
reselling multi-million dollar
residences as of a 2016 Bloomberg report
Renner had purchased and remodeled
upward of 20 houses so you and your
buddy buy the house move into it while
you're renovated and then start tearing
it apart in an interview with Bloomberg
Renner had this to say about his
relatively unglamorous Moonlighting in
real estate every home should have two
things a bar and a really nice bed I
like to entertain and having a bar to
hang out at is so much better than
hanging out in the kitchen before Renner
caught a break with SWAT in 2003 he
performed around Hollywood in a rock
group called sons of Ben which included
members of tonic you might not
immediately recognize the name tonic but
you've probably heard the group's 1996
alternative rocket If You Could Only See
Renner told Playboy in a 2015 interview
we wound up doing a bunch of acoustic
gigs around town it had an eagles kind
of sound but edgier
like a handful of other celebrities
Jeremy Renner has an Amazon store this
store contains fishing gear a portable
cooler plenty of archery paraphernalia
poison ivy ointment a flannel shirt and
jeans all the products necessary for
Jeremy Renner or an individual hoping to
emulate Jeremy Renner to go on an
adventure in The Great Outdoors however
an investigation from Slate raises
questions while not making any
assertions about renner's actual Acumen
as an Outdoorsman the article does point
out that Renner doesn't look like he
knows what he's doing while posing with
camping gear for his Amazon promotional
shots Renner points his bow and arrow
away from its Target and he sits next to
a campfire that's surrounded by
flammable objects both obvious safety
hazards additionally he holds binoculars
without looking through the lenses In
fairness Renner doesn't hunt or fish
which explains why his photo with a real
and Rod combo looks a little awkward
he's also modeling these products so you
know it wouldn't make sense to hide the
celebrity face behind those binoculars
let's face it human civilization is
insecure about its masculinity on that
note Jeremy Renner is a guy who plays
tough dudes in movies it just so happens
that he once worked as a makeup artist
at a Lancome Outlet in a Modesto
California mall and numerous Runner
profiles have treated this fact as much
more interesting and unusual than it
actually is according to the first
episode of the Renner files podcast his
stint with Lancome took place in the 90s
back then the eventual cast member of
Avengers endgame needed a day job to
cover basic living Essentials between
commercial gigs and stage plays Renner
explained in the theater we had to do
our own stage makeup I figured I could
tone it down and do it on hot girls all
day it wasn't the case it ended up being
older ladies which was just fine
nowadays Jeremy Renner is a guy you call
when your movie needs a Han Solo type of
dude irreverent and Rough Around the
Edges but basically well-intentioned
earlier in his career Hollywood nudged
Renner in a very different direction at
that point agents and casting directors
saw him more in the frequently
villainous mold of Jared Leto than as a
potential next Harrison Ford and here's
a little known fact The Avengers was
actually runner's second collaboration
with Buffy the Vampire Slayer Creator
and Avengers director Joss Whedon as it
turns out Renner played Penn a vampire
and serial killer who terrorizes Los
Angeles in a 2000 episode of The Buffy
spin-off Angel and in 2002 Renner added
his first headlining movie role to his
resume with the True Crime biopic Dahmer
if SWAT hadn't come along and shifted
his career trajectory Renner might have
evolved into the sort of actor whose
name pops up whenever it's time to cast
another Joker it's routinely reported
that Jeremy Renner does his own stunts
whenever humanly possible and he's also
never been shy about telling
interviewers his attitude about fear he
has what you might call mixed feelings
about fear he's never said he hates it
but he clearly considers it a somewhat
overrated Instinct Renner told Playboy
in 2015 fear is a huge part of most
people's lives it's a very oppressive
human emotion the most powerful human
emotion by the Magazine's account Renner
claims he did something scary every day
from his early 20s into his early 30s
and the result is a reduced
vulnerability to fear Renner told the
magazine like guns sharks Heights
success intimacy I've checked those off
the list
you're a wild man you know that
huh he's a wild man you know that
I want to shake your hand as he has no
idea if it's ever helped him on
auditions Renner doesn't credit his
supposed ability to neutralize fear for
his acting success but he does say
limited vulnerability to fear made him a
better actor in the respect that it
allows him to deliver the most honest
possible version of his characters to be
clear we think it's unlikely that Jeremy
Renner will ever convince himself that
he truly is Clint Barton and get picked
up by law enforcement after a period of
wandering around the Nevada desert
shooting arrows at hydra agents only he
can see but if it ever comes to that at
least he's got the outfit handy during a
2021 Jimmy Kimmel appearance Renner said
he never left any Marvel movie set with
props as souvenirs having been
instructed not to do that later he found
out the rest of the Avengers main cast
just took whatever they felt like
whenever they wanted in fact Chris
Hemsworth owns multiple mjolnirs and
keeps the ill-gotten magic hammers
scattered around his house after
learning this Renner helped himself to a
Hawkeye costume today when Jeremy Renner
volunteers at his daughter's elementary
school he does so in full-on Hawkeye
regalia so I said fine if I'm gonna do
it I'm gonna do it dressed as Hawkeye
and uh you know yeah why not as is
widely reported Jeremy Renner prefers to
do his own stunts as you can imagine
that makes injuries on set more likely
according to Vanity Fair a scene for the
2018 movie tag took a disastrous turn
that subjected Renner to a 20-foot fall
and a pile of broken bones Runner broke
both his arms didn't notice and agreed
to do another take of the same stunt
before heading over to the hospital the
actor told Vanity Fair they said the
arms were broken so I got them wrapped
up and then I went back to work and did
everything I could do to continue on as
we did in this instance continuing on
meant the special effects Department had
to go the extra mile and provide Runner
with CG limbs to fill in for his
temporarily immobilized arms oh it's the
only time I ever got injured was in the
comedy unlike the many other celebrity
cameos sprinkled throughout Glass Onion
and knives out mystery Jeremy renner's
appearance matters to the plot and
doesn't in the strictest sense actually
happen at least not in the flesh among
fan favorite cameos like Hugh Grant as
Benoit blanc's husband Philip Serena
Williams actually on a live monitor in
the home gym waiting for someone to ask
for a workout and all of blanc's Zoom
linked Among Us Playmates Jeremy
renner's face only appears on the label
of his own fictional hot sauce that's a
Jeremy renner's small batch hot sauce I
let him invest he sends me like a pallet
every year take a few bottles in a joke
So Meta as to be utterly believable
renner's penchant for side hustles
celebrity app Amazon store house
flipping rock music was poked fun at
with the introduction of a private label
hot sauce by the actor that shows up at
a pivotal point in the story to provide
a crucial function is writer director
Ryan Johnson an actual genius or he see
just a huge hot ones fan what if he's
both the world may never know announced
in February 2022 at the television
critics Association press tour
Renovations is a four episode reality TV
documentary that will stream on Disney
Plus in 2023. the announcement outlines
that the show finds Runner traveling the
world and helping communities by
reimagining unique purpose-built
vehicles we're not exactly sure what
that means but in December 2022 Brenner
Surety short clip to his Instagram
promoting the upcoming show by saying
there's no better way to kick off the
new year than giving back to those who
need it most given runner's established
history of remodeling homes not to
mention the play on words of the show's
title it seems fair to assume that the
actor and his team will be renovating
something for families or communities in
need this could mean RVs school buses
food trucks Mobile health clinics or
roving libraries depending on the
situation those type of vehicles
revamped could make a huge difference in
people's lives and with only four
episodes on the docket audiences might
enjoy a little slice of feel-good TV
amidst the chaos of daily life
as 2022 ended Jeremy renner's Nevada
home was snowed in on January 1st 2023
Renner was plowing the roads nearby with
his snow cat when there was an accident
and Renner suffered critical injuries to
his legs and chest the actor was
airlifted to a local hospital and
underwent two surgeries for blunt chest
trauma and Orthopedic injuries following
the surgeries Renner was moved into the
ICU and listed in critical but stable
condition according to a statement for
released by his family celebrity news
Outlet extra reported on January 2nd
that Renner was conscious stable and
speaking prior to his surgeries on
January 3rd Renner shared a new photo to
his Instagram revealing some of his
injuries CNN reported further details of
the incident clarifying that the snow
cat started rolling away when Renner was
not in the driver's seat and that the
accident occurred as he attempted to get
back in the Washoe County Sheriff's
department has impounded the vehicle and
will inspect it for mechanical issues
but called the event a tragic accident
and does not suspect Foul Play of any
kind Samantha Mast renner's publicist
released a statement earlier that same
day that said Jeremy is making positive
progress and is awake talking and in
good spirits
[Music]